if you have three price points small
medium large where you move the middle
will dictate how many of them you sell
even if you keep the small and the large
at the same price for example let's say
that we've got five dollars and ten
dollars as these things if I put the
middle very very close to the top the
top one will look like a steel compared
to the middle because it's only ten
percent more and I might get a lot more
stuff and so if I wanted to sell more
larges I would push the medium right
next to it and make it seem like a
no-brainer upsell psychologically on the
flip side if I wanted to sell more of
the middle one I would expand the
distance between the large and the
middle and so that this one would look
like the more reasonable option compared
to the premium price you should always
have a very expensive thing to sell
because you can drive more sales to the
middle while also allowing people who
want to spend the money to go buy the
super expensive thing